a
[Música]
ah
2021 arranca con un saldo trágico en los
primeros 15 días del año al menos 50
mujeres fueron víctimas de feminicidio
una media de cuatro mujeres muertas por
día es una clara tendencia al alza
aunque no tengamos los datos definitivos
de 2020 si sabemos que en el primer
semestre del año pasado
648 mujeres fueron asesinadas a manos de
sus parejas o exparejas y los expertos
advierten que eso tiene todo que ver con
el confinamiento originado por la
pandemia de coronavirus de hecho en el
estado de san paulo él más populoso del
país en los meses de más confinamiento
esos crímenes aumentaron un 41% delante
de esta situación algunas asociaciones
de mujeres critican al gobierno de jair
bolsonaro por haber según ellos reducido
los programas de prevención contra la
violencia de género y también piden más
unión de la sociedad de las
instituciones para poner en marcha
campañas de educación prevención y sobre
todo para introducir penas más rígidas
[Música]
durante las dos primeras semanas de 2021
al menos 18 mujeres fueron asesinadas en
colombia según la fundación feminicidios
colombia unas ya preocupantes cifras que
podrían ser mayores debido a la
tipificación que hace el código penal de
este homicidio que cada año genera un
subregistro según denuncian las
organizaciones feministas esto lleva a
una mayor impunidad el 75 por ciento de
los homicidios agravados por género en
latinoamérica quedan impunes según
onu-mujeres la violencia contra las
mujeres niñas y adolescentes no cesa en
el país andino sólo entre diciembre y
enero se han presentado al menos 7
feminicidios de menores de edad la
mayoría de los casos el asesino fue un
miembro de la familia las organizaciones
y activistas feministas exigen a las
autoridades mayores protecciones y
justicia para las víctimas de la
violencia machista que en el 2020 pasado
dejó más de 600 feminicidios en colombia
según observatorios independientes unas
cifras no reconocidas por el estado
siendo las mujeres rurales empobrecidas
y racial izadas las principales víctimas
[Música]
susana cerón una mujer policía en el
estado de puebla de 33 años de edad se
convirtió en una de las primeras
víctimas de feminicidio en este arranque
de año en méxico su pareja sentimental
una ex policía es el presunto autor del
feminicidio y fue capturado en el estado
de chiapas mientras tanto en el
occidente del país la desaparición de
wendy sánchez de 33 años ha causado una
intensa movilización y protestas en las
redes sociales para exigir su aparición
con vida así comienza el año en méxico
un país donde en promedio cada día son
privadas de la vida 10 mujeres ya sea
por feminicidio o por homicidio doloso
la violencia de género es uno de los
principales retos del gobierno del
presidente de lópez obrador y el estado
de méxico colindante con la capital del
país es el foco rojo pues es la entidad
donde más feminicidios se cometen
mientras en el congreso de la unión
sigue natural las distintas iniciativas
para combatir la violencia machista
[Música]